already under pressure from covet 19
argentina's hospitals are now having to
adapt again
abortion has just become legal in
argentina dr rojoldo santiago says
he has seen many women affected by
botched abortions
and is happy times have started to
change
in the past two days since the law was
implemented we have had eight requests
to terminate pregnancies
we are trying to move as fast as we can
as we have a pandemic and we are trying
to minimalize
the presence of patients in the hospital
it's a major revolution in this
overwhelmingly catholic country
in december the senate voted in favor of
legalizing abortion
women rights groups have been arguing
for years that thousands of illegal
abortions already happen annually
and they pose a major threat for women
thousands of them
end up in a hospital because of
complications but now women can have a
free and safe abortion in a public
hospital
we accompany women a lot we try to make
it easy for them without too much crying
we try to keep them away from obstetrics
and pediatrics we have other female
doctors that come here
to be with them we're ready for this
next step
doctors here say many of the women who
come already have children
and cannot afford to have another one
the new law says that a woman can have
an abortion
up to 14 weeks of pregnancy the province
of buenos aires is distributing
this booklet that explains hospitals how
to proceed
when a woman comes and requests an
abortion
this says that they have up to 10 days
to interrupt the pregnancy
timing is crucial until now abortion was
only legal in argentina in case of rape
or if a woman's life was at risk and
that's why in many conservative areas in
the country
authorities postponed legal abortions
for months forcing women to deliver
their babies
mariana carbajal has been covering women
rights issues for years
she says political will is crucial
the implementation is very clear and i
think the conservative and
fundamentalist sector does not want to
see the implementation across the
country
they will try to do what they can to
stop it that's where it is important the
political will
the political commitment to guarantee
the law is implemented and it's not just
on paper
[Applause]
prior to the passage of the new law
president alberto fernandez said
broad legalization of abortion was a
matter of public health
that needed to be addressed and that's
why hospitals in the country now see
themselves as essential
to help the government in the next step
towards securing abortion rights
nationwide al jazeera buenos aires